ja ich habe eine Nachricht mitgebracht
die ist nicht sehr schön aber sehr
wichtig und sie lautet die
migrationskrise ist zurück wir dachten
wir hätten sie bewältigt aber wir haben
sie befürchte ich nur verdrängt und im
Stundentakt gehen nun Hilferufe ein aus
den Ländern aus den Kommunen Hilferufe
aus Thüringen zum Beispiel aus Hamburg
ein ganz dramatischer hilfe-appell kamen
aus Sachsen oder neue Innenminister
Schuster mit Namen von der CDU gesagt
hat wir halten das nicht mehr aus 80%
der erstaufnahmeplätze sind bereits
belegt in der ersten Jahreshälfte sagte
Schuster kam im Schnitt 500 Menschen im
Monat nach Sachsen für den September
befürchtete der über 3000 das ist eine
versetzfachung und herr Schuster sagt
auch liebe Bundesregierung redet bitte
mit Polen und Tschechien weil es handelt
sich in vielen Fällen um
sekundärmigration es gibt Menschen die
aus Polen und Tschechien kommen aus
sicheren Drittstaaten um in Deutschland
Asyl zu beantragen noch schlimmere
Nachrichten gab es aus Bayern dort
lassen wir heute in der Süddeutschen
Zeitung zu 105 Prozent sind dort die
erstaufnahmeplätze belegt zu 105 Prozent
man befürchtet den sozialen Frieden und
ganz besonders dramatisch hörte ich nun
aus einem anderen Bundesland aus dem
schönen Baden-Württemberg dort hat sich
der Landrat von Tübingen zu Wort
gemeldet der gleichzeitig auch dem Land
des Kreistag vorsteht und er hat gesagt
ich zitiere ihn wir locken die
Flüchtlinge in die sein Wort Zitat
soziale Hängematte und der hat auf
Gespräche verwies mit ukrainischen
Männern die ihm gesagt haben wir leben
und arbeiten seit Jahr und Tag in Polen
aber wir holen unserer Familie nach
ziehen nach Deutschland und in
Deutschland bekommen wir fürs nichts tun
mehr Geld als fürs Arbeiten in Polen
insofern muss ich leider der Regierung
vorwerfen dass sie die migrationskrise
verschläft ja mehr noch dass sie den
migrationsturbo wieder anschlägt nämlich
mit dem Bürgergeld das Bürgergeld soll
nun kommen zum ersten Januar dann könnte
eine fünfköpfige Familie 2000 Euro
monatlich bekommen und ersetzt bekommen
auch noch die Warmmiete im Monat das
heißt die migrationskrise kommt der
migrationsturbonames Bürgergeld wird neu
angeworfen das ist leider schlecht für
alle Beteiligten für die Menschen die zu
uns kommen für die Menschen die hier
leben es ist schlecht für die SPD weil
sie damit das sozialdemokratische
aufstiegsversprechen beerdigt es ist
schlecht für die FDP weil sie Abschied
nimmt vom liberalen Menschenbild und es
ist schlecht für die Ampel weil sie
einfach schlecht regiert und leider
Gottes nicht die Interessen derer im
Blick hat die sie gefördert im Blick
haben sollte der Steuerzahler insofern
ist es leider momentan ein Trauerspiel
Herr Kessler ist das Bild was sie gerade
über die Migration gezeichnet haben
nicht fast gefährlich Schrägstrich
Populismus wenn man sieht also es gibt
gewisse Studien die sagen wir brauchen
400.000 Zuwanderer pro Jahr müssten wir
da nicht eher sagen okay großartig dass
Menschen zu uns kommen und im nächsten
Schritt wie schaffen wir es jetzt zu
motivieren die einen hier genannt worden
sind von dem Landrat auf den ich bezogen
habe sind die Leute hier gar nicht
arbeiten wollen also wir brauchen
natürlich Fachkräfte das ist richtig
aber wir brauchen natürlich nicht eine
ungeordnete ein irreguläre Migration wir
brauchen keine sekundär-migration
innerhalb der EU wer in sicheren
Drittstaaten ist wie in Spanien wie in
Polen wie in Portugal wie in Tschechien
der sucht sich a la carte gewissermaßen
das Land aus wo er meint die besten
Verhältnisse vor zu finden das ist
völlig rational es ist kein vorzuwerfen
aber die Ampel sitzt leider die völlig
falschen Anreiz man müsste die
Fachkräfte Migration durch Initiativen
anfordern aber stattdessen haben wir
leider Gottes eine ungeordnete Migration
das ist nicht populistisch das sind
Zahlen die ich genannt habe die
Wirklichkeit kann die populistisch sein
Populismus wäre es wenn man sich vor der
Wirklichkeit verschließt Herr jesserei
verschließt sich die Ampel vor der
Wirklichkeit also zunächst einmal ich
würde ich würde dafür warnen diese
Debatten als populistisch zu betrachten
ich finde ich finde man sollte schon
auch über diese Themen gerade in der
heutigen Zeit sehr intensiv diskutieren
es sind natürlich jetzt drei
verschiedene Themen die in einem
Zusammenhang diskutiert wurden
Fachkräfte würde ich sagen ja wir
brauchen attraktive
für den Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland
für unsere eigene Volkswirtschaft für
die Zukunft unseres Landes allerdings
machen wir dort nach wie vor die
Erfahrung dass richtig gut ausgebildete
Leute leider sich immer noch zu wenig
für Deutschland interessieren sondern
eher für Länder wie USA Kanada oder
Australien aber weniger für Deutschland
daran müssen wir arbeiten daran müssen
wir auch systematisch Arbeiten der
zweite Punkt ist natürlich die
Einwanderung in die sogenannten sozialen
Systeme das ist etwas was natürlich
außerordentlich problematisch ist denn
ja Fachkräfte ja aber diese Form der
Zuwanderung brauchen wir definitiv nicht
und darum jetzt noch diese von dem Thema
zu dem Thema komme ich auch noch weil
ich glaube dass wir nicht so ein ganz
fair wenn man das Vermischen würde
selbstverständlich ist es richtig dass
man dass der Staat keine andere keine
Anreize setzen darf damit Zuwanderung in
die sozialen Kassen in die sozialen
Systeme stattfindet
da muss der Staat aufpassen diese Form
der Zuwanderung wäre übrigens auch
außerordentliche problematisch das ist
auch Zuwanderung würde ich sagen
grundsätzlich ist es gut wenn die
Integration gelingt wenn die Integration
nicht gelingt ist Zuwanderung natürlich
ein großes Problem dann das andere Thema
Bürgergeld
so ähnlich wie das Thema was wir gerade
eben auch bisschen diskutiert haben
Corona und ich wiederhole meinen Satz ja
ich finde
anerkennen in einer Welt abholen was
jetzt mit dem Bürgergeld passiert
vielleicht hat das noch nicht jeder
mitbekommen was jetzt die Änderung ist
also im Grunde genommen das was früher
als äh Hartz IV bezeichnet wurde wird ab
dem ersten ersten basierend also das ist
ja im Koalitionsvertrag der so
vereinbart worden wird demnächst
Bürgergeld heißen also Hartz IV
überwinden Bürgergeld zum Weg zum
Bürgergeld wir haben aber festgestellt
dass wir uns einig sind in der Koalition
was den Namen anbetrifft aber die
Vorstellung was ein Bürgergeld kann oder
leisten soll ist innerhalb der Koalition
total unterschiedlich gewesen
Koalitionspartner
Bürgergeld gleichgesetzt haben mit
bedingungsloses in die Richtung kommt
und
das stimmt nicht die Sanktionen gibt es
die Sanktionen wurden ausgesetzt das
einzige das einzige was sich verändert
hat an der Stelle sind die Regelsätze
die Regel setzen geändert worden die
sind nicht erhöht worden da muss man so
fair sein die sind nur angepasst worden
an die Inflation ja gut aber Sie müssen
doch erkennen dass wir derzeit eine
Inflation
zu Ende führen wir haben beim Thema
Zuverdienstmöglichkeiten was gemacht das
da sind Erweiterungen gegeben wir haben
beim Thema Qualifizierung was gemacht es
ist auch nicht falsch es ist auch völlig
falsch was die Union im Deutschen
Bundestag erzählt das Prinzip Fördern
und Fordern bleibt weiterhin bestehen
es müssen Anreize vorhanden sein damit
Menschen aus der Arbeitslosigkeit auch
herauskommen wer arbeitet und das war
die Vorgabe der FDP bei den
Verhandlungen wer arbeitet muss mehr
haben als jemanden nicht erreicht das
Bosbach Herr Bosbach wie sehen Sie denn
das Bürgergeld also ist schon mal nicht
geändert das wird sie doch schon mal
freuen
wir mal vorne an es wird immer gesagt
500 €. damit wird der Eindruck erweckt
dass derjenige der Bürgergeld jetzt
bezieht im Monat nur 500 € zur Verfügung
hätte und dann kommt der Nachsatz wie
will man denn davon leben nehmen wir mal
ein paar mit zwei Kindern die plus
Kosten der Unterkunft die kommen locker
auf einem Betrag zwischen 2000 und
zweieinhalbtausend was aus der Sicht der
Empfänger netto ist und die Heizkosten
werden übernommen habe gerade gesagt
Kosten der Unterkunft und das sind dann
die die mitnehmen Kosten so jetzt muss
ich darüber überlegen lohnt es
wirtschaftlich lohnt es sich aus der so
aus den Sozialleistungen herauszugeben
und in eine Beschäftigung hereinzugehen
die Betroffenen werden ihr jetziges
staatliches Einkommen nicht vergleichen
mit ihrem zukünftigen Bruttoeinkommen
sondern mit dem zukünftigen
Nettoeinkommen wenn sie zwei Kinder
haben sind die Regelsätze für die Kinder
höher als das staatliche Kindergeld was
sie bezieht wenn sie in eine
Beschäftigung gehen sehen wir mal einen
durchschnittliches Gehalt dann werden
Sie feststellen dass der dass die
Differenz vielleicht zwei drei
vierhundert Euro ist im Monat viele
Rechnungen und dann stellen sich viele
die Frage lohnt sich das sie haben recht
es ist eine Angleichung an die sehr hohe
Inflationsrate ja das Glück haben die
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer aber
nicht sondern die müssen dann dem Wege
des Tarif aus Tarif Auseinandersetzung
oder des Streiks versuchen dass sie
keine reale das schaffen wir die kalte
Progression auf das Einkommensverlust
haben das ist gerade geschehen Tarif auf
Rädern ändert aber nichts daran dass sie
für jede Lohnerhöhung streiten müssen
während das durch den Gesetzgeber hier
beim Hartz IV Bürgergeld per Gesetz
nachgeholt worden ist wenn sie den
Menschen den Anreiz nehmen in eine
Beschäftigung hereinzugehen wird es auch
viele die zu uns kommen dass keine Frage
der Ethnie keine Frage der Herkunft
werden viele Feststellungen wie viel es
in Deutschland gibt weitaus mehr als in
den Herkunftsländern mit einer
Beschäftigung
wobei ist davon gehe ich auch zur
Ehrenrettung der Betroffenen es wird
auch viele geben sehr viele die sagen es
ist für mich eine Frage der würde ich
möchte gar nicht vom vom Staat in diesem
Land aber ich bin fassungslos dass sie
jetzt hier erzählen es hält sich
ansonsten nichts geändert wir haben
plötzlich ein Schonvermögen von 150.000
Euro
150.000 Euro wir haben auch zwei Wagen
wenn wenn wenn zweifache Berufstätigkeit
war so schon Vermögen das heißt obwohl
sie ein Vermögen haben von 150.000 ein
schönes Einfamilienhaus bewohnen soll
der Steuerzahler das finanzieren der
möglicherweise ein geringeres Einkommen
und in den ersten sechs Monaten soll es
keine Sanktionen geben mit
der Name terminversorgnis beim
Arbeitsamt es ist schon ein Unterschied
zu Harz
sofort Angebote Ablegen der Terminen
nicht einhält wer sich an
Weiterbildungsmaßnahmen nicht hält der
wird selbstverständlich in diesem System
sanktioniert selbstverständlich wird in
diesem System sanktioniert da war ich
auch auf dem Wissensstand von Mosbach
gestern
nach der Werbung mitteilen wer jetzt
recht hat am Tisch aber Frau würde wie
nehmen sie die Stimmung war lohnt sich
arbeiten noch
also ich finde grundsätzlich also das
muss sie sein diese Diskussion dreht
sich gerade sehr sehr schnell also wir
sind von hier migration
ich weiß es nicht richtig wo ich meinen
Pin setzen soll in diesem Moment und ich
höre und und lerne gerade sehr viel
ja ich finde es ist auch in meiner
Verantwortung meine Kinder so zu
erziehen dass ich arbeiten lohnt weil
Arbeiten Spaß macht ja und das geht und
für mich ist es so dass ich auch sage
ich werde meinen Kindern auch einfach
beibringen zu sagen okay oder eher die
Richtung nicht zwingen du musst arbeiten
du musst was leisten muss Geld verdienen
sondern selbst rauszufinden was könnte
mir Spaß machen damit ich später das
Geld verdienen kann und das ist mir
wirklich Spaß macht das zu verdienen und
da sehe ich jetzt so meine Verantwortung
muss ich sagen was sie jetzt mit dem
anderen das überlasse ich erstmal ihnen
wir können ansprechen
alle die auf dem Land wiege kommen alle
ausnahmslos alle kommen ja aus sicheren
verfolgenden befreien EU-Staaten oder
aus der schnuckeligen Schweiz auch
unstreitig ein gefestigter
demokratischer Staat sie stammen aus
anderen Ländern aber sie kommen über
verfolgungsfreie Staaten da möchten Sie
aber nicht bleiben sondern sie möchten
lieber nach Deutschland oder über
Deutschland weiter wandern auch heute
noch weisen wir niemanden an der Grenze
der einen Asylantrag stellt das
allerdings kann ich jetzt der Ampel
nicht Anlassen sondern das ist die
Politik seit Anfang September 2015 die
CDU glaube ich im Kanzleramt ja das war
eine eine politische Entscheidung dass
wir jeden ins Land lassen einen
Asylantrag stellt natürlich weisen wir
zurück wenn jemand aus dem visaflichen
Stadt kommt kein Visum hat und sagt ich
möchte gerne nach Deutschland einreisen
dann weisen wir auch heute zurück wenn
aber wieder kommt und sagt jetzt stelle
ich einen Asylantrag dann aber die
ampela Koalitionsvertrag geschrieben
rückführungsoffensiv und ich finde
definitiv nicht statt es finden verzogen
kommen wir zum Thema von Frau würdig das
ist nämlich auch sehr wichtig